my my next kind of question around
around this
is that um would it be fair to say that
then um given a synthesis of what you're
talking about with clinical metabolomics
and what aubrey de grey
and all these other um evolve these
um rejuvenating to homeostatic youthful
homeostatic capacity
would it be fair to say that um our
synthesis of all of you guys in like the
2020s and beyond
is basically going to be something like
a
an an an artificial general intelligence
that has
the entire medical corpus and all of the
um the the the ref or the the reference
pop pop the reference population corpus
um and that then takes in
through sensors that are on my toilet
and everywhere else um that are going to
be taking a live
stream of all of those biometrics as my
individual
and then cross-referencing them with the
reference population
and then sending me um interventions
to continue having rej that youthful
homeostatic capacity that's um
that's a utopian future right but you
must remember alan
that the reference range will be also
dependent on your race and your
geography
yes uh for example we just did a show on
on population genetics when we were in
china and
um hufang zhang was having that exact
same
um issue with how there was only the
european
data set yeah yes yeah and that's a
problem also with
uh interpreting the genetics the genes
right now right
because their references are either
chinese or european
or uh or north american right so
so each country um will need to develop
its own reference ranges
that's so interesting wow yes
every country every country
wow every country that's so interesting
and even
separate even tribes in those countries
look
they eat if you take a look you know
what makes a culture well we were just
talking about the philippines you were
saying there's 76
dialects right yes yeah so then that
means there's all these different
cult subcultures in the yeah
yeah and the the cuisine is regional
right yeah is original
there's a region that uses a lot of
coconut milk
there is a region you know um that uses
lots of
just totally spicy stuff yes you know so
so um even in those you could see
already very very that's why
in and this is what i say when you're
dealing with health optimization
it has to be individualized we can only
do case reports for you
what is being demanded of us is case
work across populations
say dude we don't work with populations
we work with the population of
of uh organisms that is you you are the
ecosystem that we work with
and therefore what is good for you
is not necessarily what's good for the
next person right
we just have a fair idea of what the
body does and what the body needs
because
it's more or less uh universal that you
know you cannot synthesize
vitamins and that's why they call
vitamins because you take them in
right there are certain essential
there's a certain essential uh minerals
that
have to be uh taken in right um and so
on and
and we know that we know that about
our make and model as a human body right
and
one of the biggest problems that we have
is that the megan model of the human
body
is intended for the paleolithic period
right it's not intended for now
we have created a world that is
uh that where our bodies are actually
unsuited for
right artificial lights you know um
and uh you know uh polluted air and uh
you know not exercising you know you
used to
to to uh to walk to work in the fields
and and so on and even before
agriculture we
walked a lot because we were nomadic
right so would it be fair to say
something along the lines of to continue
our analogy that's i think
really flourishing flowering right now
would it would it be
like that the vehicle itself is
us in that sense and there's a make
there's a model there's a yes
there's a year too you said that it was
very important and then that the older
vehicles
were had that you know the dashboards
only had a couple
variables on the i uh now they're having
hundreds and
we want to get that constant measurement
and the in that id
in that analogy it would be like you
know if you if your vehicle
is manufactured in the united states or
in china or in south africa or germany
or tenure wherever
it it ends up being a
a unique to that specific
make um for your vehicle and you're
gonna eat those specific things be
exposed to those certain cultural things
even your language
and and all this type yeah yeah but from
an evolutionary point of view
now we will shift from what you just
said from an evolutionary
point of view right we are actually
with the world that we have created is
the world
for teslas right
gullwing if you prefer those um
but our bodies are make and model us
human beings is a ford model t
ah this is perfect that's our body is a
ford
ford model t right right yeah and and
the
the world that we have created is
actually suited for a tesla yeah and
and so we're brilliant
species right we can of course we do
we have no we have no our model t's have
no seat belts and we're
we're on we're in the insane realm of
the internet uh
with all of the yeah and then and you
know um
you know uh our bodies are not intended
to eat soylent
for example uh yeah or
all the high fructose corn syrups and um
yes yes yeah so we we are intended for
that period so
what do we do so so for me it's it's
really simple right
now we have some technology so
for example for your artificial light
control your lighting system
there are lighting systems out there now
that can simulate you know a 12-hour
you know or sunrise and sunset and so on
and so forth right if you're staying
indoors
um the software is on the computer like
flux and stuff like that are very good
yeah yeah and and then you could
uh you know there's a reason why your
supplements is because you know that
you are not going to be eating foods
rich and this and that so
you know what when your tests show that
you need them you take them
right because you're getting
deficiencies in them because your body
is used to
taking them in food otherwise you know
in in in the olden times in the
paleolithic times
right uh so a lot of our make and model
is made for that time but we have
created a world
that is not suited for amica model
anymore so what do we do
you know we respond by you know
having air air filters and air cleaners
at our house
right making sure that our home air
exchanges are adequate
yeah right making sure that our we still
have the same basic needs like
we need to go out to sunlight if you
cannot go to sunlight you know like me i
suffer from seasonal effective disorder
because i'm a tropical boy i need really
more sunlight they have darker skin
right you need you need more um higher
levels of vitamin d so what i do
i have a vitamin d lamp that has uvb
interesting and
i exposed myself so you you you
essentially
uh uh compensate by using technologies
that are available to you
or um um things that we have invented
right in order to compensate for it
because there's no going back
right i cannot bring you to a time when
there was no electric bulb
or no radio or no electricity
you know that's not possible anymore so
why not make your you know retrofit your
your home to be emf shielded right um
interesting so and that's just the
reason
why you know people say they they're
biohacking all sorts of things right
this is a framework by which you can
make
you can hang all of your hacks you could
look at
epigenetics you know uh bioenergetics
microbiota got microbiota mitochondria
exposomics chronobiology evolutionary
medicine
and you could hang all of your hacks in
there
in a logical way right there's a logic
now you're not just saying oh it's
because they're saying it's good for me
or if you want to help someone as a
practitioner
say right because i know that there
would be less doctors interested in this
and there would be more practitioners
who actually would be interested in
doing this is now there's a logical way
where you could hang all of your hacks
oh that belongs here or that belongs
here yes yes you're not
you're not haphazard anymore with the
way you do things with the way you help
your clients right
so i'm doing this because x yeah yeah
this is this is super interesting on an
on an
economic perspective because we've been
we've been rolling i want to i want to
hit
still some um really interesting points
that was our
that was kind of our most heavy section
um
which is the thesis of of an ethos of
what
um you care about and what all these
great leaders in the fields of
biotechnology especially care about now
you're sure i care about that
[Laughter]
i want to know this uh we we can end on
this
um perspective on that we can end that
section on this specific perspective
around that
which is it's very interesting
how the amount of money
that is sort of spent on this what like
what like people like jessica zitter and
other people have called like this end
of life
conveyor belt and palliative care um
and like people just having you know
dying preferences and being able to like
spiritually connect on their way out or
all this type of different type of stuff
but also what all the problems that we
have with
um heart disease and alzheimer's and all
these other
cancers and all these other problems
that we have um
that there's so much money that we can
quantify that is spent
on the disease of biomarkers
versus when we spend them on these um
medical
biomarkers health biomarkers multi-omics
these health biomarkers
and then so what's interesting is that
so there's both a significant amount of
economic cost that we decrease on that
downstream end
but then we also spend more money on
this upstream
end as well so there's actually in a
sense there's
a continuation of great economic um
flourishing
so it's like you would subscribe in a
sense to maybe
a five dollar a month or ten or twenty
dollar a month or whatever it is
um plan where your constant stream
of biometrics is being fed up into that
agi
corpus that is then taking your
individual
and cross-referencing that with the
publishing then providing you with
with intervention and but ultimately
ultimately what um you said in one of
your
graphics which i really liked a lot
which was that
um it's so simple in terms of these
you know if you do think about it like
you're continuing the analogy
like you said the model t itself that is
now
in the tesla world um like we are
that you can do basic things to very
quickly ramp up your model t to be
closer to a tesla which are basically
the most
ancient wisdoms are you've said
um sleep well eat well hydrate well
breathe well
move well sun well ground well relate
well
love well and if you do those things you
can very easily work your way
into a healthier